back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
what up boys what up dead - did the dog
dog pound dairy D to the D to the I feel
like everything guys in forever
good is it a family name there sorry
Brendan never cares about other people
I'm gonna do it for us is it a family
name or is it a nickname cuz Derek so
outlandish what is where did you come
from there is a [ __ ] family name how
do you know cuz I know Derek I'm on the
road all the time with them okay well
let me ask him something then go Derek
is it okay if this freaking big twink
over here yeah yeah he's okay if the guy
who looks like you embezzled money from
NWA that's your question first of all I
don't know it was hard to embezzle money
from end of you just pain your hotel
bills and you just started screwing you
over
go ahead yeah my dad's name's Rick and
then he didn't want another he didn't
want another person to be named Rick so
he made me do it like French daddy dis
right D Rick D Rick ever ever dip
Everett no Derek Derek Derek yeah
dear I lick my balls yeah that movie
dude you are making fun of him a and
he's heard it a million times do have
you what do you get Derek you're like my
ball look at that one a lot I get
postman a lot the mailman that's awesome
yeah we're taking package through the
bat why is Derek the postman post him
and they just pair read his column he
post post post man dude come over play
hoops with us mean D play hoops every
Thursday how do you flame hey when's the
last slice doin rocks dude uh the last
hoops I played I played about a year ago
dude almost fought this [ __ ] Persian
dude he's being an [ __ ] they play
real D don't the hosts Persians - you're
way too serious yeah yeah it was like it
was like an LA kind of Persian guy you
try selling at carpet afterwards he had
like slaves on the side yeah that's a
gold yeah that the gold piercing in the
nose he left on a ship full of gold
that's how he left the gym very intense
pretty hairy too right oh these are like
Cologne uh yeah his big defensive move
was he just wrapped a bunch of hair
around you by like hoops isn't your
thing
oh dude hoops is definitely my thing bro
probably what probably I was probably a
pretty I was a good pretty good
who's player yeah sounds like it I took
long enough to get out hey did you uh
did you play sports growing up though
yeah man like what was your thing though
like did you gravitate towards anything
besides I owe towards me see uh outdoor
activities for nice hmm a little bit of
kites man this [ __ ] what's the last time
so some people would shoot him people
would shoot him down where I was from
bro when's the last time y'all so you do
talk about a drone when's the last time
someone flew a kite oh I saw a couple in
Santa Monica the other day on 4th of
July really yeah I haven't seen any I
don't know how long oh yeah it was
either a kite or might have had been a
message for help somebody to fly there's
a moke signal a lot of homeless people
out there in Santa Monica or even in Los
all over Los Angeles getting crazy man
you think some of these billionaires
celebrities are always complaining about
it would let them come stay with them
you know yeah I'm staying when your crew
rooms
Chelsea Handler let them come live at
your [ __ ] [ __ ] house and drink half
your booze anyway obviously got a little
bit anger in me yeah all right but
anyway let's crack into its dead dog
what do we got Dee huh well you have a
children's hat on let's don't pretend
that going on look I can't you look like
you're wearing Kimmy gibbler's hat bro
that's my joke you look like punk that
rooster Joe okay okay punk Brewster dude
you look like bebop and rocksteady had a
gay cousin you look how you sell merch
for kitten play what are you wearing
right now you only wear the hat like
that bro like you're wearing to look at
you
you're like a morning DJ back on kale
said neither ride traffic wide-open door
guards Billy were playing with rocks you
kids call footballs doctor I ran the
long neck last night broke the Jews a DJ
Aladdin if he came out of a [ __ ] tank
twinkled a transgender magician you
should go check on Mary gots no talent
called America's Got Talent is like a
[ __ ] gay owl sick of freaking skies
so we get this guy a singer in a dick
sick of talking this human halfway house
over here oh my bad she called longnecks
yeah that goes - okay bro yeah see he
told me what we're gonna make a wish
situation by with your show
he's always it one time somebody thought
he was a parking meter and just came up
and put money in his mouth no joke he
weighs like sixty pounds dude does he oh
yeah oh yeah he does
you need to start a rap okay that's good
Oh Brendan just hopscotching through the
alphabet time to pay the bill man bro
you don't look that well oh well it
might lose you know what you're losing
it all man but it all starts with your
hair you know that bro hey what in the
man downstairs getting a little limp -
you know I'm saying yeah well hey limp
City well you've heard the splash
brothers on the opposite of that well
you could have not told everybody that
but thank you for sharing Brendan what
I'm saying is
that look hair-loss you know getting
that little [ __ ] limp chump those are
things that happen to men as we age you
know 66% of men lose their hair by age
35 dang my bros then we start losing
their hair the gigs tough out there man
so we got a one-stop-shop hitter for you
I'm talking about hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for the dick piece just
for the bros I'm talking about for hims
dot-com right hims connects you with
real doctors and medical grade solutions
to treat hair loss so if your hair is
starting to frickin just not show up
like the French then it's time to
tighten it up these are well known
generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help your hair also
they can help with that dick game too if
your dicks not showing up on that Friday
night date Yeah right bro how great
would it be to have your erect penis
looking at your beautiful hair dude that
can be you two for one two for one and
our listeners get a trial month of hymns
for just $5 today right now while
supplies last
see website for full details and safety
info this would cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor pharmacy but go to
forums dot-com slash cats that's fo r
hims con /k 80s for hems comm slash cats
time to buy few more pants dude
neighborhoods are crazy man they are man
you gotta watch out for each other
there's nothing better when you're
neighbors looking out burglars trying to
get in maybe someone's trying to steal
your package not on my watch cuz there's
an app called neighbors and spy ring
mm-hmm and my whole neighborhood's on
anyone what's come in my neighborhood
yeah this dude boom it's like that
yep it's legal snitches it's teamwork
against those haters man it's teamwork
snitch on each other
yup is beautiful cuz the net with the
neighbors app you receive real-time
crime and safety alerts from your
neighbors if there's a fire if
somebody's trying to burgle somebody's
still in a bike somebody lifting an
Amazon package I got those coyote
bandits coming my lawn try to eat all my
carrots Oh sided steel my son away not
on my watch my neighbor's got my
that's right that's what I'm saying boy
he gots good eyesight and he still has
his son what's up
the fact is this app is making it easier
for my neighbors to work together and
keep the community safe there's millions
of people using it already it's like a
new neighborhood watch program powered
by real people powered by the people and
powered by ring yep so if you guys want
to see what's going on in your
neighborhood right now Tech's cats pod
that's right
txt cat's pod to the number 5 5 5 - 8 8
8 that's K 80s p OD to the number 5 5 5
8 8 8 to download the neighbors app
today make your neighborhood safe today
with neighbors app by brain yup that's
cats pod 2 5 5 5 8 8 8 support the
podcast
let's get we'll start with a new segment
little chive my ride I think people send
in so what is this segment people send
in pictures of the ride we just breathe
into it people sending in their cars or
their friends or family members cars
it's like what was that show on MTV
about the rides him I tried to pimp my
wreck they made some crazy ride it's
like dude I don't want to [ __ ] 10
gallon fish tank in my Ferrari these
fish are gonna die man or like I need a
dog cage in the back of my Viper yeah
actually seem like something you would
have I'm sorry you don't have a
cappuccino maker in the back of my
[ __ ] Toyota Tercel weird things where
were the celebrity that walk out and
pretend it was cool yeah they were turn
in like a dope ride then if y'all pink
with like a lava lamp in the middle bike
shoes don't pimp my ride Road let's do
it a lava lamp idea we never made you
put them in your car right oh you don't
have a car you can just carry around the
Ebers you're in yeah I don't tell my
selling them talking about a real
business yeah I know a dude bus bus
lamps yeah they're booming what were
they called those lamps no they weren't
lava lamps no they were called lava
lamps we had a different name I think
yeah the bus lamp bust bulbs I think bus
bulbs yeah I like bus lamps you do bus
land
bus lamps out of business
okay Mona's sea-monkeys with lights what
else you got
let's get into something up first we got
Mac Beth's from Stratford Missouri this
is Mac best ride he's 18 he's got a 1979
Oldsmobile d don'ts 88 with huh D
steeled off the set of Goodfellas right
he said this is a picky took when it's
accelerator and brakes when at the same
time the radiator blew up and it started
billowing smoke out the hood like feel
when he hasn't smoked in a few days
right
the car is 40 years old I'm 18 Wow
gang [ __ ] bro dude you know some parents
have had some [ __ ] sessions in the
backseat back there they got those bench
seats and they're comfy [ __ ] I'll take a
nice warm nap in these cars man you put
on a little freaking jazz and just drive
down the 405 boy that's the best sleep
you ever get well that does sound
beautiful dude it definitely sounds
beautiful sleeping to jazz music while
going down the interstate now there's a
real safe experience well I'm not
driving your [ __ ] chipmunk okay we'll
say that then when you're telling a
story they assume that man nobody
assumed - dude I saw a big frickin meat
hook climbing into the backseat a big
[ __ ] rainbow human ham hot jump into
the backseat with jasmine take a nap
cars going forward like [ __ ] hell man
loser ease first of all Goodfellas hood
jealous brothers [ __ ] right you know
dude you could grow meat on the front of
that thing you got so much smoke coming
out of that ho that's that salami hitter
right there it's warm in the front toe
couple of telling mafia heads out the
back yeah dude I just think hopefully it
has to have a body in the trunk I bet it
runs on bodies in the trunk bodies in
the trunk bodies in the front Italian
meatball six inches there this is the
yellow wolf [ __ ] header right there
bro yes the only hit he has
yeah old I'll just kill I like yellow uh
yeah sure really sounded like for any
things that you he's like we're gonna be
like I'm a rapist uh no I'm not
and he thinks if he just says no I'm not
he's not a rapist dude rapist Oh
whatever bro this cars [ __ ] dope
though oh yeah that really summed it up
I'm gonna say this man this the car you
could seem like you could do detective
work you seem like you could smoke a
smoke on a nice spliff in here the air
and the tires alone is probably from
1977 the whole vibes that 70 vibes man
oh you could pick up a 68 year old woman
easily in this bit oh do you pick up an
18 year old who thinks you're safe and
this this uh this is a serial killers
car as well because it looks pretty safe
yeah I agree this is uh this is I mean
this is like that debt Ted Bundy Jeep
Wrangler really I mean this thing is
just beautiful so that Charles Manson
whip I'm not mad at it yeah that's CM
dub what I'm saying is you could roll
around and let I would let people
coagulate in the back of this thing for
about $80 a pop a lot of people would
love to have a little bit of that that
nostalgia that's what I'm saying lost
algin yeah busting on them velvet seats
doing taxicab confessions a little good
fella confessions okay it could be a new
business set up a couple GoPros pick up
a couple of honey's in the back mm-hmm
couple footlong Italian subs yeah that
bolds Mobil do it and get bold with it
yeah you're bold in the back baby cat
have you ever made love in a vehicle
let's get over to see what's in the
culture corner yes a type of vehicle
well vehicle summary uh no the back of a
greyhound I was always going to prom
praise God praise God I don't erection
Wow way to prom yes way there and then
way back is everyone watching huh was
everyone watching ready yeah I was all
the way in the back yeah where's
everybody else
in the front in the front you it no wow
everybody's mind their own business I
was like euphoria what is that
Shawn HBO don't you don't have TV don't
worry about it oh wow first of all Thank
You cat
for being brave enough to admit thank
you for being honest there cuz at least
one of us is in this room well a guy
gave me a grandma coke one time to [ __ ]
him watch him jerk off on a gijón headed
up to Natchez Mississippi and I didn't
do it I didn't do it dude I did a couple
bumps at a coke but I didn't watch
here's the thing do you want tell the
truth on the story do you take a couple
bumps then jack them off well I did
that's how that goes
no one's giving you cocaine to watch
them jackals cows now it's not the way
this rodeo goes this guy was a
homosexual and he was willing to nah
dude you jacked him I was there bro I'd
remember if I Jack some guy off that I
need you were high how do you know huh
you were high you remember even more
brah
oh really it not you remember yeah it
Hans's your memory it's like a limitless
yeah it's like whacking dudes off yeah
but it's you have it but you I limited
at Jack and dudes off dude that's right
that's not the drug it's limitless so
Jack them off bro god bless a greyhound
beautiful beautiful story cat Derek you
ever made love and a look like you make
love in the back of a [ __ ] bakery
truck Eclipse Mitsubishi Eclipse
[ __ ] in cars as harder as you get
older that's one thing that is when I'm
great and I'm big dude you know [ __ ]
they're like they're like this top like
this yeah that's true man nothing's
harder to do than make love into cars
you get over that's one of the girls
look like the bet neck lady from that
Netflix series all over my car like this
what car anyway keep it his screeching
halt Derek ever made love in the back of
a Toyota 4runner anything like well yeah
I only was [ __ ] in cars so probably
like two years ago gang [ __ ] I finally
got a plane [ __ ] homeless [ __ ] hashtag
broke [ __ ] bro [ __ ] in cars and parks
baby that's what I did it har what was
your favorite car yeah yeah what was
your favorite car what my favorite car
yes
notable Harry's mug didn't bark you
delinquents little birds has it done the
park
crime Americans you [ __ ] delete in
crime you idiots
that's not crying yes it is baby we have
sex in a park maybe in New Orleans
that's a crime not in the middle of the
day you can't but at night knowing kids
a funky cat has the decency to make love
in the back of a [ __ ] group bus okay
that's the only real one in here [ __ ]
swing set monster dude swing set
monsters - you're telling me out of all
the drugs and dude you've been these
porta-potties you've never made love in
a park it what a surprise you are you
kidding me parks are for playing man
parks are for snacks Kyle's crazy yeah
drugs yeah man
parks are getting coked up dude or watch
one of your neighbors shoot up and yeah
I'm [ __ ] somebody gonna know well come
on dude no guy I'm not gonna agree to
that all right well shout out to this
Goodfellas vehicle yeah get this [ __ ] up
yes clearly has a frickin problem up
next we got Ben Mortimer Ben Mortimer
rat bastard crew gang brah got the rat
bastard crew car on this one oh I like
the tetanus shot front it's got on it
huh
oh [ __ ] that Mad Max vibe
wow this thing looks like a roller skate
that um was like an extra on Breaking
Bad
it also looks at it looks like you two
make the cut on ghostbusters Buster's
that's what it looks like this thing it
looks like ghost bus to do this looks
like Casper just came all over us stack
of metal and rubber this is what's up
with all the rusty grill bro oh you're
driving into kids dreams with this thing
you got to shut it kids nightmares this
is rat bastard crew on the front first
of all this guy's obviously from a
different realm of time his name is
Mortimer he's named after a marker in
the Bill Cosby cartoon egg
zoom in on the door there what Stanley
that Roth finked I would stand below it
industries he's Jewish he's a
businessman
this is a tax write-off oh this is a tax
write-off what's going on it's a tax rap
to catch ghosts yeah as a ghost business
oh dude this is I think this could be a
Jewish here Claire this could be Ted
Bundy's burg right here this guy think I
think so man wrong thing a hundred
percent
it seems very uh peligro so it seems
unsafe seems like a a tetanus shot if
he's your bird driver you feel me yeah
Phil my joke coming back at me brought
like his [ __ ] jokes trail yeah
through that [ __ ] into the desk did you
say CTE Oliver said you have to have a
tetanus shot to be an uber driver I said
I said this car comes with the tetanus
oh [ __ ] my bad
it's okay okay what about this only
spare tires on the car how is that not a
uh well if it only fits all right I love
how he has defenders on the side oh now
that he knows there's the only money put
into the car was the fenders and the
logos Mad Max on that how that thing's
super mad man actually this thing's
pretty dope yeah it is the more I look
at the more I dig it
yeah it's kind of so rare to have a
unique vehicle these days he's clearly
in England driving the wrong side of the
road if he asked me oh he's in [ __ ]
bling 'ln brothers [ __ ] is nice as [ __ ]
over there always from 1975 this thing
is dope dude people are still in ships
over there you'll see a ship going down
the street it's still doing English very
different than here dude yeah you're
gonna cop you're gonna conflict they
fight out fighting out with swords you
know that oh yeah why not
what else you got deal no I'm not mad
that guy Mortimer dude shut up to the
rat bastard crew - I don't know who they
are
here's an ad from the king of the state
I don't know about that Brendan but he's
just 19 okay and everybody needs a great
pair of wireless earbuds I know but
they're so expensive man you got
anything fresh and cool for me look
before you go drop in hundreds of
dollars on a pair you got to check out
the wireless earbuds from my boys rake
on
yep what but are they like crazy
expensive look I'm gonna tell you
Brendan all right rake on earbuds
started about half of the price it's 50%
Brendan yeah but do they sound good of
the price of previous wireless earbuds
on the market yes they sound just
amazing dude if you're gonna tell me
that this company was founded by Ray J
yes it was nah
no that's not her car DB jams with them
yeah my friend Randy JR Smith they're
the founders of this company recons e-50
wireless earbuds they've totally changed
the game man you see I like a person
with a hearing aid a senior citizen
fuck'em bro that ain't what we're doing
dude
these are icons 'if if t they're so
comfortable is so easy to take them
anywhere and they look great man and
they sound great I'm excited
ray con offers their Wireless for
everyone in a range of fun colors at
unbeatable price yeah good for you Ray J
go to buy rake on.com slash cast to get
15% off those sound hitters that's buy
rake on.com slash Katz
that's right bu y ra y co n comm /k ats
get 15% off those beautiful [ __ ] ear
testicles baby get that sound in your
[ __ ] brain Brook do your nuts get
right get them nuts in years and get
that sound right if you've been eyeing a
pair now is the time to get an amazing
deal you're tired of just walking around
having a sing yourself change it get ear
bugs you're like Ray J by Ray con
dot-com / K 80s be like Ray J someone's
got to pay for Brennan's coffee habit
what do we got teeth you guys aren't
here some for Q going you wanna hear
some fan submissions of roasts my house
o little roast my hoes I got a couple
that were Peters I'll dive dish I've
just a few out to people I'll take some
you take something by people you mean me
no I mean people that are undeserving
like our listeners I'm and I'm gonna
apologize for that first one I thought
was so funny
Brennan looks like Shia LaBeouf try to
turn into the Hulk but got stuck halfway
[Laughter]
that's a mic contra name that Michael
honcho is not a real man you submit that
day that's a real one this next one from
Gebbie dubs this is Jerry dubs Theo
looks like the kind of guy to take his
parents to small claim courts over
unpaid Shore money probably out of $520
did so much work and she never paid us
man I never paid us dude and we're
supposed to get paid and at the end of
the week we done things that had lost
all the money every week and I was doing
laundry and cleaning the house and it
was just [ __ ] insane bro and opening
a beer Jesus Christ anyway it's not
funny if he came from steals mom this
last ones for both of you I thought I
was great from chance coffee y'all look
like the Timon and Pumbaa that didn't
make the Lion King that's the best thing
you've ever said man there's a good man
where do you pick those up from there Oh
YouTube also going through the comments
you Instagram too or no histogram to but
the youtubes lose one directiy yeah
those are funny God you guys are like
Timon and Pumbaa
it's
that might be the funniest one yeah but
you could lose weight too - some of it
is the times - what yeah what you have a
body of a 14 year old transgender girl
find some dumbbells do a push-up every
now and then bro quit drinking soy
lattes push-up look and talking about
working out put on a push-up bra dee
[ __ ] chubby muffin quit doing [ __ ]
yoga and talking to people about [ __ ]
politics and grab a [ __ ] incline
bench all right we got some debate club
well your people come this far and you
stop at the [ __ ] start your blood
pressure check bro ain't nobody in here
in great shape that's in the best shape
yeah all right guys this first ones from
CLD is a little safer debate club
growing up I was a huge fan of The
Simpsons didn't really pay much
attention to King and Hill I know throw
me in jail you want me to I'll give a
[ __ ] King though but then I start
rewashing something king of the hill and
realize there were
that show was a lot more funny do they
give credit for propane it got me
thinking because I was underrated
because I was underrated what do you
guys think was to better anime show
Simpsons or king of the hill I'll leave
you two to go on fight and Duke it out
Gang Gang Klaus buzz drip drip drip
that's Derek I'm king of the hill man
king of King Hill was weakest [ __ ]
orders to stand by a fence for [ __ ]
ten seasons
dude The Simpsons all they did sit on a
couch they killed a dude and they
predicted the future from Trump winning
the area 51 Simpsons don't have a cow
man come on bro Lisa Simpson eat my
shorts boy do mr. burns I think that
shit's on Bolton's Family Guy family
yeah okay misleading I think it's kind
of bizarre The Simpsons was good when
Santa's Little Helper was really popping
off if I could decline baby never grew
up yeah what the baby's name was much
larger is the mom will be Maggie Maggie
dude time to get rid of the Baba the
sucker shot on for ten years
yeah dude complain when you [ __ ] have
that thing in your mouth - I don't trust
that crusty clown around the kids either
pedophile with makeup on all the goddamn
time he was awesome dude
Montgomery burns the senior citizen that
wouldn't die a lot of good characters
Ned Flanders man oh yeah Oh Ned Flanders
body hug - howdy neighbor
what about the guy though what about the
hot daughter on king of the hill I'm not
familiar with Kenya anyone else in here
no cuz we're goddamn money or somebody
was titty Ginny I like LuAnn sorry were
you yeah you were King and he'll fin
well
Golu yeah let's see that king of the
hill cast man let's see a [ __ ] decent
looking king of the hill just turned
into f is for family
another exact same show but bill Burgess
made it way that hot daughter bro
mmm-hmm she's a christina applegate of
our generation you walk muppet stand out
but gate can still get it
look at that frickin uh we got [ __ ] dog
you get this [ __ ] on my face
Simpsons destroys this and I'm really
competition I thought didn't say Family
Guy Simpson what do you think there
wanker brain bro king of the hill pretty
decent I'll say that only BB do you have
in your town I don't know anyone who
likes freakin king of the hill
did I ask King of the day alright bro
whatever did what what's the fan say
seventy seventy four percent Simpsons
Wow of course Inspector Gadget watch it
dude and member they made that busted
Matthew broad read movie or where the
[ __ ] his name is remember and he was
Inspector Gadget sounds horrible it was
awful dude remember the big guy with the
cat and a metal arm yeah he's always
like rubbing his cat a Vietnam veteran
yeah and just pissed yeah I don't know
what Inspector Gadget trying to solve
every goddamn episode you they're worse
dude look just admit you're trying to
[ __ ] Carmen Sandiego and chill bro yeah
dude you're searching for her let's get
out of this topic man it's all day up
next we got Tara Buchanan this is Tara
what's up girl damn [ __ ] did she just
win a Sunday July 7 2000 and delight
2019 my name is Tara Buchanan guitar
welcome to you Calgary Alberta I'm gonna
show that your coach good oh I got a
debate club question for you guys you uh
Matthew McConaughey a Brad Pitt
let me hear what you've got to say about
that hitter gang buzz-buzz
peace out you guys and Theo thank you so
much for you doing Brendan don't know
you very well but warming up to you
every day
wow the truth resin
dating through society okay what else
Thank You Tara for reaching out and
thanks for mentioning Brendon when
you're asking me this question
- that's good Matty Mac or Brad Pitt Oh
both dimy dimes listen Matthew
McConaughey made all the [ __ ]
romantic comedies didn't he do you have
to take your shirt off in every picker
picture running on the beach every time
did that's Baywatch you're thinking of
no it's Matthew Brett
it's [ __ ] Matthew McConaughey man but
then he got serious from a Dallas buyers
club that's the [ __ ] right there on HBO
true detective a time to kill them right
yeah yeah that was good but Brad Pitt
has those [ __ ] hitter Rosie they were
is he just a big boy Fight Club Mike
looks good Troy oh [ __ ] people haven't
seen Troy eight nine out of ten people
haven't seen Troy descriptions 1107 sad
that was good sevens good red maybe
[ __ ] too much rain Dolph yeah too
dark too much rain Jemma space creeps me
out maybe not want to use Amazon okay
but I'll say this what's in the box
what's in the box yeah Matthew
McConaughey do you remember this and
then Texas lost the [ __ ] Superbowl
yeah I think the ego got a little crazy
with McConaughey there for a bit yeah
for being awesome
I like Matthew McConaughey and I think
about it but also we got all the gifts
from God I mean brat brat Pitt have more
pot mark kind of skin he seemed more
like everyday dude McConaughey seemed a
little bit more wild and flamboyant do
Brad Pitt makes those [ __ ] heaters
man if you think about all the movies
Moneyball inglorious basterds game over
top three of all time
oh yeah Brad Pitt is that magic donkey
brother yeah he doesn't miss dude oh he
misses bro oh this is in life in being
married and [ __ ] Belize day or whatever
that movie that animated sequel sequence
thing cartoon Brad panic cartoon yeah he
was a mine he's the voice on mega mine
yeah what the [ __ ] is that never heard
of it so else a great movie
Farrell's the what dude yeah for you boy
bro what do Brad Pitt has been in some
horrible [ __ ] name um you can't say mega
maaan is a huge [ __ ] hit never heard
of it
so you know I have heard of a lot of
things that are much more popular than
that Wade Boggs chocolate those are
[ __ ] hits bro Matthew McConaughey um
what else did he do a time to kill bro
saving [ __ ] racism you know yeah you
mentioned that one what else she got
Matthew McConaughey Joe launched I'll
give you that
that was dope never seen it okay How to
Lose a Guy in 10 days that was dope
failure to launch is not the name of
Derek and his girlfriend's exhibition
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
all over do Matthew McConaughey was in I
think what else was the end somebody
helped me out those wicked commercials
yeah there's Lincoln commercials
nobody's playing pool that doesn't mean
what a buy [ __ ] car what else did huh
fight out fire clubs his biggest was
buyer's club that's his best one no
Jared Leto
Oh Daisy confused he's in some cooler if
you did yeah
I'm so lucky for him otherwise he was in
uh Jerry Maguire it wasn't your right
alright let's get out of this I love
ball tamago with I love both of them
because I love romantic comedies but
I'll go with my boy Brad Pitt I'm gonna
succeed on this one I'm gonna give you
that Brad Pitt yeah
54% McConaughey whoa I was on to
something should have stuck just alright
boys one more sorry boys I let y'all
down I should've stuck with my instinct
sorry Matthew McConaughey Klan we got
Johnny Martino from Saratoga new game
are out there from Saratoga Nate Oh
sitting in Metairie uh after a sheet
dress let's go it's like feels podcasts
to do this that looks way more like he's
broadcasting live from this guy's
broadcasting live from his own
gallbladder [ __ ] Hospital
first of all this guy seemed like a nice
guy
rig a human more everybody is blast to
fit a woman's genes
a little lemon no judge everybody Theo
this looks more like chin when he was
almost 300 pounds yes he hats
he's white what are we talking about but
chin gets very wide Nick's - it looks
like Nick's like long distant like
distant relatives like a cousin yeah
three times removed
yeah I met him in Nick would match on
grind match on grandfather family tree
would be a wreath from Nick's enemy sub
madami dude I've been synonym emails
Alta
no this guy's cool you know that I care
about you more than amen also your
crazies jacking off to either Wolverine
professor oh let me just say this
there's definitely a Deadpool between
his legs
and that was pretty funny I'll give
myself that probably like asteroids
coming back out of here steroids sewed
your body shape like that now you're
gonna be drinking smoothies all the time
a little muscle for fucksakes
I'm doing shows you do a few push-ups
for me they're not on your knees what
did you quit eating push pops dude okay
and you've been sweating up that deck
are you [ __ ] monster you're the one
who used to shoot up so you could be in
good Oh bro dude sorry I'm in reading
school books I'm saying is not all of us
were shooting up test 200 so we could be
in a [ __ ] house you know that was it I
kept thinking Master P I couldn't get to
MC Hammer in my head well past four you
would've been 22 though dude i sat in
coach an extra mr. P one time about nine
years ago try to pump me out on a United
flight man it did break my [ __ ] heart
dude what was his main uh make him say
huh make him sick
lovely her deluded [ __ ] time
y'all at the Big Bang
we had the big bags dude that [ __ ] was a
bass player was cash money there's no no
knocker no no movement this before see
murder went to jail mystical yeah oh
damn they all went to jail too yeah sad
man gang bruh playboy your hustler
what's your thoughts on do you remember
Newark or not you might be too young for
I do remember him but I remember like
whenever I'd find a dirty magazine he
would be like in the woods or by a
dumpster and be all shredded up yeah
they were going out of style when I was
coming oh praise God did I open up their
[ __ ] it was too much when I was like
12 was then I don't think they would do
that hustler was raunchy dude playboy
was classy I could read the articles you
know I'm saying there's cool stuff also
had some big titty girls so like you got
best of both world nobody believes you
made it through an article just gives
your mommy's to read you hustler at
night to go to sleep
oh he's mad at me man what do you got
bro the articles you've read and the
articles you wear have something in
common both real small I think you're
right about this man I think playboy
hustler was too much they shouldn't had
it out there I remember a bike in seven
miles over to my buddy's house just to
go and take a dump at his buddy's dad's
house so I could read a hustler magazine
and masturbate then I'd be too tired to
bike home and I would sleep on their
floor and uh and that went on for
probably two years by two years so 16
years well no and so it's uh you know
it's I think the hustle was too much man
I you know raunchy man this your Bush it
was raunchy man but you but the joy was
you had to find one and then you had to
hide it you couldn't bring it home cuz
your mom was gonna find it and you had
to hide it somewhere so you had to do
that outdoors you had to do that kind of
Boo Radley that you gotta stuff it in a
tree space or something where only you
know your buddy know where to put then
somebody else came upon it so then you
got two or three people
kind of
circa met nag nag the gating this titli
Jesus Christ exactly where I was going
but I don't Oh Bravo you're going to the
moon with that one you're a dude here's
the thing I always associated hustler I
hate trying to help you for your breast
I always associated hustler with faces
of death because my buddy who had him
would put him together in the same
hiding spot oh so I'd have to grab the
face of death like oh god no I'm gonna
jack off though
and what was face it at the magazine
video and just show people dying so you
put the video with the magazine I didn't
my creepy friend Jason did Oh
Jason who call him out nope can't do it
Wow seem like he's not a real person and
it's you
let's keep it moving there 65% with
Playboy yeah respectable hero and
Playboy's like we're not gonna show
women anymore which can do fun articles
and then their sales went you know what
we're gonna bring back the tits let's do
the tits well a shout-out to you big boy
out there you know shirtless sending
that in man yeah that takes a lot of
balls go shirtless especially it good
for you dude keep hanging bro yanking
reading the magazines dude keep yanking
and reading well it's better than
pornography brothers better than
watching that pornography that's
definitely not yes it is Brendon up next
we got some relationship advice same guy
no this is from 19-year old zip oh 19 I
live
oh wow the model when he meets a model
man is a young boy hoping she can hear
you - no no no gangbang bro you're 19
don't gangbang well he can do what he
wants first of all first of all I'd say
speak up because your girls have no idea
if you like her or not cuz you're
whispering to us
so I'd say speak up the third thing is
you're 19 yeah best man wins dude roll
out the red carpet
it take her to MC theatres get the Red
Vines get your dick out in the popcorn
aisle you know I'm saying go see Lion
King [ __ ] French kiss in the back
yeah you know I'm saying may the best
man win
give it up I'll give it to that yeah may
the best man win man you can't like
there's no I'll tell you this why you're
sending this video and your boy is
sending her a message brother you gotta
get in there bro and get the action be
that action Jackson bro don't be that
[ __ ] dead in Ben you know so you got
to really take care of yourself bro you
know like if you drink it though here's
the swag going on I'm saying
good-looking kid dude I'm a [ __ ]
adult and I don't look at children like
that
you seem like a male I'll say that and
you seem you know like you're alive
now it also seem like you could be in
hiding right now because you're talking
at a very unique decibel known to people
that are playing hide-and-go-seek oh my
god it gonna be 18 but the lady man
first of all it sounds like you both
have never met her it's if you just know
her from snapchat
let's go to a woman's perspective poor
cat poultra corner what's okay I mean I
agree with you guys best man wins
you guys are 19 you guys need to duke it
out [ __ ] race run a 40-yard dash no
everwood's
fight you e do not fight you don't need
to fight race each other but also she
probably has her mind up about who she
likes more does she she's 18
yes or she can motor bike in this if
there are two choices you always want
one a little more than the other Oh
always oh wow
he does have some swag I told you the
good-looking kid I'd like to see the
other kid and then when maybe we can
think we can pick for her you want to
see the other kid yeah maybe set there
eight it's how many young kids you need
to see today guy huh
we're not just one team I'm gonna
predict a winner I think what we do at
Eastern sponsor date the little twink
Connor yeah we'll send him on a date
actually I think it's not a bad idea to
do a date and have a sentence and video
from it but I want to know this do you
think Kat say if say if she likes the
other guy more like you said maybe they
like the woman might already know right
yeah what's his move if he's the guy in
second place how does he play it to have
a chance maybe even down the road like
what is his them what are the mistakes
he could make and what are the things he
could actually do
correctly I mean just because she likes
the other guy a little more doesn't
necessarily mean he's out of the race
he's just got to step up his game
you mean like get more Instagram
followers she linked up with long their
kazoom [ __ ] Wow
I mean you just can't mentally she
challenged boy under the [ __ ] Brendan
[ __ ] he's not mentally challenged yes
he is dude he's a nice dude I know he's
nice he's also mentally generally yeah
he does two things
you know you trying to throw them under
your little [ __ ] scooter or whatever
you're driving these days you're a
little [ __ ] you talk about their
might I saw you with your second scooter
pic the other day you [ __ ] animal
doing wheelies on it yeah I don't know
cats you can pick up give him some
advice cat cuz this [ __ ] guy looks
like he's about to slit his own wrists
definitely don't split your own wrists
saying you're gonna be okay advice it
gets better nice to these kids nowadays
bro winter doesn't come they [ __ ]
kill themselves man dude yeah if you for
it and you picked up our second season
70 kids kill themselves well there's a
new documentary out this mate says it's
cool to kill yourself 13 reasons to kill
your buddy or whatever it's so weird man
it's like hey kids here's a cool idea
make some [ __ ] tapes and buggin off
yourself if soon dad doesn't like their
pictures they off themselves it just
times are different man different man so
at least this guy has the balls to reach
out to some [ __ ] guys who have really
made some shitty decisions like Brendan
and myself that's why we had cat
throwing that suggestion so he's not out
of it cat he can still win this race he
could still win he just got to figure
out what she wants I mean at that age if
I got I was real simple if you bought me
boba and popcorn chicken I was yours
damn god damn girl yeah well nobody did
it that's the thing ah that's the thing
boba and chicken yes we can fry chicken
but pop yeah she's good deep-fried
popcorn chicken Jesus I don't know where
he gets that weird that from Derrick
where are you gonna [ __ ] headed there
dude Jesus you're an idiot man I'm an
idiot and you're a racist I'm a racist
dude you're an idiot
yeah and your racist idiot dude let's
get this guy a cigarette whatever dude
you're out of your mind
next we got a rip my drip sorry Derek
it's okay buddy first I'm sorry my
friends racist keep going yeah I'm sorry
my friend haha I'm sorry my friends
races and blames it keys from New
Orleans dude I'm from New Orleans man
I'm sorry my friend thinks that the
fifth grade is high school okay I'm here
bro
this is Sebastian from Ontario Sebastian
whoo [ __ ] what is it what is this who is
this home depot psychopath bro he looks
like Kant applause okay this guy who
looks like he shirt says I don't exist
back with Santa Claus on it for the
listeners bro he looks like one of the
sons of the Wet Bandits okay dude he
looks so mean Derek what do you think
about it he looks exactly like the bad
guy from The Smurfs oh my god my god a
hair and everything that's a good call
this guy's one bad break off I'm just
[ __ ] up that entire wherever he works
he works in a shop it's called a shop
dude is where men work at that's not a
shop dude that's the back of [ __ ]
Costco it's not a shop look at that
giant [ __ ] fan look at all the [ __ ]
they're selling you didn't get couches
at a shop look back there he hasn't
gloves who was close to her car dude
those guys were good you know who wear
them guys who were serious about the
[ __ ] that's who wears them cuz they
don't want calluses of their sands
there's a green boat next to him I don't
know what that is yeah you do what this
might be area 51 Oh could be two guys
it's either alien
he looks like uh he looks a little bit
like John Malkovich's angry son
dude if like he looks like of mice and
Meineke like he works at a [ __ ] brake
shop he looks [ __ ] pissed man he just
looks so dark yeah this is all mining
equipment he's at a mining it place look
he looks at miner no wait really
yeah hell yeah dude shoutout to miners
dish out the miners shove to the Nazi
shots my shots no shout to - shout-out
to the [ __ ] who escaped the basement and
Pulp Fiction and now found a job Wow
I don't see him like that at all esteem
as a young man who eat I'm not young
they'll shut up two hands for sponsoring
this guy what does this thing is called
Punk mile no this is just a rip my drip
forgot his job how about his [ __ ]
Columbine blower half okay his style I
will say this great gloves dark clothing
a picture of one trench coat away from
joining the band my man you definitely
should not be allowed inside of
Burlington Coat Factory okay you're
going from there so I think yeah I would
brighten up the the clothing calves what
are you throwing palette there's more
than plastic what do you think he could
do
I mean maybe black is a good call he's a
minor he gets dirty real easily sure
that's good maybe he has to wear black
um you know but he wants to let everyone
know that he loves Christmas yeah or he
does it yeah open up the cone on your
style in your heart bro there's more
than black yeah it's funny cuz he
dresses in black but looks like he
doesn't like it
so that's kind of an interesting look
man he's pissed yes we're blood god
bless you brother we'll be thinking
about you man yeah well good luck dude
wow thanks for close to that JPEG then
you guys feel better when he closed it
going to pay on this guy wind up on
first 48 well see ya next we got Jess
Mayer Jess admirer Oh what is going on
with this wrong daddy this is Jess Mayer
all she sent in was PS brendan is daddy
who all she said Oh goddamn Tommy so
respected Nick picking all the goddamn
submissions thank you for finally adding
to this wow she seems I don't know
Brendan finally the only good-looking
person we've ever had on the show it
calls me daddy
[ __ ] yeah what do you think about this
kind of lady when you see her Derek is
that Wonder Woman I thought I thought
she was gal gadot man or the sexiest
flight attendant ever you know what I
mean oh yeah dude dang dude Delta Delta
Delta can I help you help you help you
can I fly [ __ ] Spirit Airlines if
she's working bro I'll bring a couple
extra bags and my freaking skeet on
board hell yeah I'm gonna have a carry
on lady
these balls dude Derek's gonna bring his
girl for an onboard [ __ ] this shuttle
[Laughter]
I said she's never gonna let you know
sorry David dang Darris don't get out
the drop this is turn from playboy
hustler episode man oh well I feel bad
for digs girl I don't feel bad for her
she's gorgeous
yeah yeah don't touch over here shut up
Mel I will watch you delinquent first we
got Amanda Ken Martin for qinger sting
it this is Amanda Amanda I said me first
Brandon - a Doug's wait what are we
doing I - is this relationship advice
the dogs you guys King interesting at
big dogs these are gigantic
I think bigger the better no one likes a
small frail guy who doesn't do bench or
incline so I think you want a bigger
meteor like if I if you're picking ribs
you want the beef once you feel me oh
yeah you're a little baby back pork rib
over there dude that's thick [ __ ] be
free Oh bro I'm that brisket you're that
risk look all I'm saying is if a frisbee
will kill it it's not a dog that's my
motto
yeah so one of these big bad boys could
obviously catch a frisbee in a heartbeat
these are some beautiful animals right
there some Huskies uh I say husky bro
that's a [ __ ] Saint Bernard on the
Left which I love like that fan of st.
Bernard Parish down in Louisiana bro
shout-out to her big pearly whites as
well and the hitters in the front what
was the other dog the other dog looked
like I think it's a Weimaraner dog
dinner that dog trying get to them tit
that's chocolate lamb does she realize
these dogs just like these dogs we may
want to do a uh what's he calling you
have somebody check the police check on
someone yeah just like these big dogs
definitely one of them jeans
Florida let's definitely order a WC per
you know right so super Norris ketchup
adhi from michigan daddy
Addie's also nickname for a [ __ ] drug
shut up to their water Brendan I love
you love the show guys Gang Gang buzz
buzz girl Wow first of all she seemed
like a beautiful young lady and uh your
boyfriend seemed like he picked a very
vibrant and unique person that can
unicycle so thank you she just wants to
know what we think of unicycles in
general usually a pass for me now she's
the hottest you know cycler I've ever
seen usually they don't look like that
really so weird guy third street trying
to hustle me for money with ripped jeans
you know I'm saying and a meth problem
usually I don't like him yeah dude
ripped jeans is also a hoverin his DNA
profile so definitely he said he's got
some real good man but yeah you seem
like a beautiful young lady what if she
asked also get a huffy no don't do that
Brendon keep doing what you do do
whatever you want to do old school
things beekeeping javelin whatever you
got to do you want to build one of those
with those rubber shades in your yard
and do that and shoot those pumpkins
like those little people used to do on
TLC champ dude here's the thing you're
talking about Mythbusters no little
people big world
I don't watch them they disgust me
really the Roloffs
they [ __ ] or low hum of the ball or
the rich midgets yeah
I like the Ridge it's they call him
first of all and second of all they grew
pumpkins bro okay him for ya imagine me
a little and grown the biggest [ __ ]
vegetable in the universe pretty
inflamed you know what pretty inspiring
yeah unbelievably inspiring yeah I get
unicycle you don't need two wheels two
wheels is for [ __ ] creeps bra pervert
there's just anyone make some money
start juggling on that [ __ ] yeah that's
Venice Beach guys make a lot of money on
unicycles and juggling yeah that's cute
cool send a cute girl out to Venice
Beach on a unicycle you want money or
not bro how about this make money a
different way and don't end up a sex
trafficked person okay that's fair yeah
here's what I'm saying is you get out
there honey you do you alright and tell
your boyfriend I said hello and
everything yeah me too buzz buzz
unicycles I'll say yeah boys that's the
episode we did it I sweat it through my
shirt yeah Tang tang tang bags that I'm
in Nashville in Portland taking this tea
fat K calm Nashville Portland Denver
just got an ounce all at your boy it's
my homecoming all right where that song
we're coming home and uh I'll be in San
Francisco this weekend at Cobbs Comedy
Cellar and I've never been there before
comedy club cops comedy club the cellar
bro that's Robin Williams grounds bro oh
it is yeah well never been there before
and I'm definitely excited that's good
I'd be a good time CD Levon Sam friends
yeah Hobbes a special place
Hobbes especial I'm excited to go there
first time ever so a bunch of unicycles
out there oh yeah unicycles unisex they
got it all bro
yes you know gang bang gang gang-bang
buzz bus
[Music]
nice name
[Music]